let me ask
for um
for therapy for advice for wisdom in uh
returning to Eric Weinstein and maybe
give some guidance to understanding
his view on um his attempt at a theory
of everything that he calls geometric
Unity that he told me that you may have
some inkling of an under understanding
of
if you were to describe this Theory to
aliens that visited Earth
laughs
uh how would you do it or you could try
if it was just me
visiting Earth uh how would you describe
your best understanding of it
he he shared with me some of it when I
was in New York at Colombia like 11
years ago we actually spent a lot of
time where he explained to me and I
found it beautiful
it has a very um original idea at the
core of it where you have this instead
of four dimensional instead of 10
dimensional he has 14 dimensional space
and I thought it was it was really
original and this is exactly it goes to
the point I made earlier that we need
new ideas
I feel that without some fundamentally
new idea we won't be able to get closer
to understanding our universe now I have
a problem with the whole idea of Theory
of Everything You know I don't believe
that one exists nor nor that we should
um
aim to construct one
and I think it's it's really um not to
offend anybody but it's ultimately a
fault of education system of physicists
like in mathematics we do not we're not
brought up we're not educated as
mathematicians with the idea that one
day we will come up with the theory of
everything even though as a joke I said
that language program is mathematical
Theory of Everything
but I mean it's a kind of a
tongue-in-cheek but isn't a little bit
kind of that it's not really because
first of all it doesn't cover all fields
of mathematics and it covers specific
phenomena but isn't it spiritually
striving towards the same platonic form
of the theory of everything like
connecting connecting but connecting
doesn't mean that it covers everything
right so you could connect two things
and then you have a infinitely many
other things which are outside of the
purview of this connection
that's how it is in mathematics I I feel
and I would venture to say that most
mathematicians look at it this way like
there's no idea that somehow I think
it's actually impossible because we're
not talking about such a thing as like
one Universe we're talking about all
possible universes of all possible
dimensions and so on it is just not
feasible to have a unified unify
everything in one equation
now physicists on the other hand have
been brought up educated for decades
with this idea and to me and I I'm sure
I should say that but I feel like it's a
kind of an ultimate ego trip
so that I have come up with the unified
I have found the intensity of everything
it's me and this is my name will be on
it I think a lot of physicists get
educated this way especially men take it
seriously yeah and I've seen that happen
and I think it is counterproductive I
think that a lot of people agree that
this debate is kind of I feel like it's
kind of settled I think I hear it less
and less
but
I disagree with the whole premise so you
uh it's interesting because because both
are interesting points you made which is
you don't think a Theory of Everything
exists and
you don't think the pursuit of a theory
of everything is good so I think you
spoke to the second thing which is
basically uh that the pursuit of a
theory of everything becomes like a drug
to the human ego that's right so it is a
huge motivating factor I don't deny that
but I feel that it's there are better
ways to motivate people than like that
then this way okay so
um I would say for instance if one
because then it's not a game of Winner
Takes to all in some sense
and In fairness when physicists say
Theory of Everything Grand unified
theory they mean something very specific
which is unifying the standard model and
Einstein's relativity Theory which is
the theory of gravity
so they don't necessarily a lot of
physics may say this worse but they
don't really mean them
I think it's important to realize that
that in my opinion that's not productive
and it's not visible anyway so having
said that there are some theories are
better than others obviously so for
instance Eric's theory has as far as I
understand does have a certain way of
producing some of the elementary
particles that we see and as well as the
force of gravity so it does have that
promise
I feel that from at least from the place
where I had seen it about 10 years ago
it still required a lot of work to get
to the point of actually saying that it
does work because
you know a lot there are a lot of
elements it's a it's a huge Enterprise
to have a theory because you have just
to describe the field sort of the the
building blocks of the theory it's
already tremendous undertaking and he's
trying to do it for curved spaces and
greater generality which is what makes
it so unique and so beautiful
but then that on top of that there are
this issue of quantization of actually
describing them as Quantum field Theory
and the quantum field Theory even as a
language as a framework is currently
incomplete in my opinion and not only my
opinion it's like everybody's uh it's uh
everybody agrees on that that it's a
it's a
it's a collection of Tricks so it's a
collection of tools it's a toolbox but
it is not a a
consistent rigorous Theory like number
theory in mathematics physicists has
still have still been able to derive
predictions
uh from it by and um confirm them with
to Great accuracy but the underpinnings
that it doesn't have the real grigorous
Foundation from mathematical perspective
so in that sense even if
in that framework a new Theory
could
um lead to an explanation of some some
new explanation of some phenomena it
would still be incomplete in a sense
because it wouldn't be mathematically
rigorous issue what I mean because the
whole framework is not yet on a firm
foundation
so it's not consistent I why is it that
the Universe should have
so that's to your first point do you
think the universe has a beautiful clean
when you show up and meet God and
there's one equation on the board and
the two of you just chuckle the things
such equation exists
yeah there are such equations for
instance
let's say I am
interested in particular question right
so
in the language program say so moving
away from physics so let's talk about
math so
in in the context of language program
I have recently developed with my
co-authors 18 Golf and cash done and
kind of a new strand a new flavor of the
language program if you will
but so far it's a sort of it's a vision
it's a set of conjectures
which we have proved in some cases but
not in full generality
so yes I would like to to use your
framework for me the Creator and ask her
what is the explanation of this and it
may well be that you will answer in a
way that I will I'll just burst out
laughing it's like how could we not see
it you see so that I totally see
but I don't see one equation governing
one one equation governing them all
not one equation to govern them all but
it does seem that such equations exist
well she will tell you something and you
look back and say how could I not see it
it seems like the the truth at the end
of the day is simple
that we're seeking especially through
mathematics it seems somehow simple the
the nature reality the thing that
governs it seems to be simple I wonder
why that is
and I also wonder if it's not totally
Incorrect and we're just craving the
simplicity
and then
mixing into the whole conversation about
how much The Observer that creates
Simplicity is part of the answer
it's a whole big giant mess
or a whole a whole big beautiful
painting
or Symphony